well we have one last birthday surprise
and this one is for rachel that's right
yeah it's a surprise guest actually
that's right she's a hilarious actor
sultry singer and your real life bestie
rachel let's hear it for the life of
every party and one of the other great
comedians of our time on a gossip
[Applause]
i am so honored
it's a very special day for my work
husband
well i got your presents i i want you to
know i shot them i shopped my house you
did yeah
that's the best i love that she's got a
great house one might say in a panic it
might be some spices well let me just
say and i did it's a reuse recycle part
because i didn't i'm trying to be more
conscious this is a fun grammar game
because you're smarter than everybody
and i thought it would be a good way for
you do you like our word play we like we
enjoy some birthdays do you bananagrams
or like do any games like this i got you
some compost from brooklyn
[Applause]
yeah so that that came from my from my
shelf and it's very useful and i thought
you could do some home potting with your
brooklyn compost and then this is my
favorite hack baking book because i know
you worry about baking i just want to
worry about baking who knows it's a lot
of it's it's
really helped me anna truly all right
well will you guys since we are here at
the news desk honor us with getting some
headlines oh absolutely okay let's do it
i want your take on this there's a brand
new study out right now
rating the top 10 grossest words of all
time all right and the new york post
reports the language platform probably
asked ten thousand adults and the
results are in so any guesses
um well you know moist is gonna always
ding ding ding
uh moist i would say moist is number
four on the list well done right that's
shocking
number one me too what about um
uh i mean i find the word panty
revolting because i don't feel that we
should be talking about women's clothing
as baby clothes i don't want anyone to
get their panties in a bunch but it's
not on the list okay
good usage what else okay
i'll tell you the top four is moist
number three is seepage
um number two is phlegm uh the number
one grossest word according to this
study is
pus
all right rachel it's your story oh geez
okay um next we've got fashion writer
esther newman at women and home standing
up for a simple message she asks us to
please celebrate our sagging boobs
oh
her message her message is not about
bras women should corral the gals in a
bra if they like or let them dangle if
they so choose hanging with the danger
but overall she just wants us to stop
knocking the low-hanging knockers yes
and simply accept the crap i just fit
this gravity exists
sagging tatas are natural beautiful and
don't need to be fixed no they don't
i prefer well seasoned to sagging
a well-seasoned breast that makes me
think you're putting like holy [ __ ]
it just means it's been around
it's been marinating for a
time um you know it's funny i remember
being on snl this like week um where i
was made fun of on the golden globes
because i wore this dress
um it made my looks great you look
really well it was it was being talked
about so i went on snl and tina and amy
gave me some redemption um if you show
that yeah there we go oh yeah
and drew that was like a really lauded
performance didn't you win a sag award
for that
[Music]